With magnification we've found that if a texel covered too many pixels, we
could just make our original checkered texter larger and larger so that about
one texel covered one pixel. With minification we'd like each pixel to cover no
more than one texel. The GPU has built into it, special functionality that
implements an algorithm called mip mapping. With mip mapping the GPU computes
approximately what the texel to pixel ratio is. If this ratio is less than one
Magnification happens and the mag filter takes effect. If this ratio is greater
than one, minification is happening. This is where mid mapping comes in. What
the GPU does, is determines the ratio of texels to pixels. If this ratio gets
much larger than one to one A lower resolution version of the texture is used
instead. As this ratio gets higher and higher, a lower and lower resolution of
the texture gets used. These textures can be thought of as forming a pyramid.
For example, say a pixel needs the texture color. Instead of taking whatever
texel happens to cover the center of the pixel down at the bottom level. The
GPU determines the texel to pixel ratio for this pixel to see how high up the
pyramid to go. The texture at this level of the pyramid is then sampled. Since
the ratio of texels to pixels is about one to one for this lower resolution
texture, the rendering looks much better without the noise we saw before. In
fact, for even better quality rendering, we can set the GPU to linearly
interpolate between levels. This is called trilinear filtering. Say our ratio
is in between two pyramid levels. We then sample the texture above and below
from where our sample is in the pyramid, and interpolate between these two
samples. My example pyramid was not drawn to scale. Within the GPU, the pyramid
is created and stored in powers of 2. That is, if you start with a texture
that's 64 by 64, the pyramid is formed with this texture, a 32 by 32 texture, a
16 by 16 texture, 8 by 8. Four by four, two by two and one by one at the end.
This sort of textures is called the mipmap pyramid or the mipmap chain. Each
smaller texture is derived from the larger one. One technique is to simply
average the four texels of the larger texture to make the smaller which can be
done in advance or by the GPU itself. There are some subtleties, such as gamma
correction, that can change how these levels are formed. That's for a later
lesson. This is an important point, so pay attention. You want to make your
textures to be powers of two in size, both in rows and columns. You will not be
able to use mipmapping if you don't. GPUs generally expect powers of two, so
don't disappoint them, unless you know what you're doing and have a very good
reason for doing so. Give the new version of the demo a try. You can now pick
mipmapping as a filtering option for minification.